the head coach of Loyola Chicago
basketball in his seventh season is such
Porter Moser here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you coach I'm great rich thanks
for having me what in the world is this
run like for you it's been it's been an
awesome ride rich it really has in it
it's been all you know four years
putting together with with high
character guys and you know anytime you
go through something like this in and
you're you have such a close-knit group
and it just makes that ride much sweeter
but you know the another huge factor is
I'm from the Chicago area born and
raised
tuned Chicago sports Cubs
Blackhawks Bears Bulls and I just to be
able to have Chicago this excited and to
go you know it's an awesome sports town
a prideful sports town and they're going
crazy and our university is it's just
been a great ride so who from I guess
the Chicago sports circle has reached
out to you that that you either haven't
heard from or you had heard from and
you're excited to have heard from based
on your we've heard from everybody I
mean a lot of the Cubs were tweeting
filmed-- Rizzo you know John les has
been tweeting out of Scottie Pippen a
lot of the goals the Blackhawks
organizations affairs the White Sox
every one of them and it's really cool I
mean pepper reached out to one of our
players from Chicago so it's just been a
surreal ride for these guys because I'm
telling you it was a complete grassroots
rebuild I mean there was a couple years
ago in the media that nobody was at our
games
how about Obama has he reached out yes
tweeting now he tweeted out you know go
Ramblers and you know just really cool I
mean there's just a ton of pride going
on in the area yeah sister Jean huh I
mean she this is this is more than 15
minutes here Porter I mean we're we're
pushing an hour now this is great I mean
tell me about her and your first meeting
with her back in the day for you Porter
you know what so I got the job seven
years ago and I met her obviously right
away but like she
she's just our university comfort
blanket I think she's she's just energy
smiling the the the thing the country
sees right now her in a wheelchair is
not sister Jean she has had a hit they
she had a leg accident she's usually you
to see her going around booking around
in her Nikes you know around campus
totally self-sufficient at 98 and he's
just got a lot of energy and she's I
mean think about she's 98 she's been
there for like 60 some years and just a
fixture of our campus and what I am and
we're just seeing all the kids go up and
hug her and what's what's their
relationship like she's our team
chaplain you know she says the prayer
with her guys for the game but you know
she's got a relationship with the whole
university of student body she's got an
office at our Damon Student Center and
there's always students coming in and
out of it she just Pete you know she
stopped to talk to everybody people and
so it's not just our team it's the
entire university and uh but the guys
know I mean she says you know soon
follows about for a prayer before every
game and she emails them after games
telling them you know nice job and
everything and even after the losses so
she's just a comfort blanket you know
for our guys well it's all working to
Porter and you know obviously there may
be some divine power at work here
because you are the first team since the
1981 st. Joseph team to win consecutive
games in a single tournament NC double-a
tournament by one point I mean the
margin of victory has been so slim what
has it been like for you and this team
in the huddle game on the line once
again where you guys just look each
other in the eye and then execute we've
been here so much like you know close
games we got a group of winners you know
who's by design we stood up set out
building this thing you got seven guys
in our team that won state championships
and you know they just believed we
practiced the last four minutes of the
game almost every day like throughout
the year we just will put four minutes
up last four minutes and so many
situations come up so you just find ways
to win and these guys believe the other
thing that's that's a huge trade of ours
is our own so
these guys are willing to pass it dr.
Ingram hits the game-winner against
Miami is up on the podium and he says
you know what any one of these guys
could have hit it the next night it was
Clayton custard he gets up there and
says you know any one of these guys
could have hit that shot and then last
night was so important Clayton a lot of
times a lot of guys they hit one and all
the notoriety in publicity came after
Clayton hit that shot to send us in the
sweet 16 he comes off that ball screen
and a lot of guys with oh I want to do
it again and he drew a defender and kick
it - Marcus towns and then market towns
hit it and it's just there's a there's a
huge unselfishness in a confidence that
in each other that that we we have in
our locker room
Porter Moser head coach of Loyola
University of Chicago men's basketball
here on the Rich Eisen show let's talk
about your journey a little bit player
at Creighton right so you that was your
first tournament action if you will
yeah it was as a player back in 1989 I
guess we won't talk about the game is a
one and done if you don't right I mean
unless you want to I remember the game
like it was yesterday they were a loaded
Missouri team each my crawler and a
bunch of guys out there so but you know
as you were making your journey as an
assistant and then coaching at Arkansas
Little Rock and Illinois State as the
head of the program a name that leaps
out to me was when you were an assistant
after Illinois State for Rick Majerus
and I'm wondering what what did he
instill in you Porter that perhaps
you're calling on you're pulling on
right about now in this run you know
Richie he was uh he was a huge influence
on my life and my coaching life but you
know I went to Arkansas Little Rock and
then I took over a program that won four
games and we had to rebuild going 118 or
more every time I was there and then I
took the Illinois State job and we had
really turned Little Rock turned the
corner but I went to Illinois State my
state school and they were at the time
and last place so I was in another
rebuild and I a seven-year deal because
it was a last-place team at the time and
after four years I thought we were
primed to really make a job in the
business part of it we had a new ad they
brought out three years of my contract
and then I went with
Jerris and that was the best experience
because it's solidified sometimes when
he goes through adversity and if you do
get another chance you know you feel
anxiety like I maybe I got to skip steps
because I got to have it happen faster
because of the business in the
expectation and going with coach majerus
was just from the very beginning he's
like let's do it with great kids kids at
one let's teach them develop them the
attention to detail of teaching and
sitting in a boardroom and watching his
mind work on game planning on how we're
gonna stop teams was I mean I just it
was just a different experience and when
I got the job at Loyola it was another
grassroots rebuild and he just kept on
calling me that first Jim's like do it
the right way
do it with winning kids and it just
solidified you know what there's a right
way to do it don't skip steps
don't don't fall into the trap of
everybody wants it now build it build a
program not a team and that's what we've
done it learn and you got a great
Majoris story for me one that not oh my
god I got a whole journal of oh give me
give me your favorite oh oh man I mean
but you know eating with him was such a
pleasure what it was the hardest part of
the job you know everyone said you're
gonna go work for coach majerus he's
gonna grind you to the bone my coach
isn't gonna grind with the bone I mean
I'm just working the hard part is he
wanted to go to dinner every night and
it was it wasn't just dinner
it was an event dinner was a three-hour
event and I loved those things I mean he
needed grease and spoons
you know we i remember going on a
recruiting trip with him three hours
away we had two different stops at
Culver's you know for like an hour each
he's got one he loved to talk and
converse and talk ball you know that
that that book my life on a napkin is
the most apropos book title we've
written x and o's on everything from
napkins at Culver's to the fine linens
on the hill an Italian restaurant in st.
Louis and then you know Kansas State and
Kentucky where'd you watch that coach
where'd you I was there doing a lot of
the media stuff okay my assistants
obviously were courtside I went out to
the courtside for a little bit
so to watch over then we took the team
back and then I to the hotel and we
watch the rest here okay and then in a
couple minutes I have left with you the
directions are all set right you know
how to get to the arena you know you
know what it's just we just have to over
just like having a couple turnovers
early in the game you gotta overcome it
and serve the fact that's what happened
we had a couple turnovers to start the
game better overcometh settle down there
you go you had to find the directions I
mean how does a bus driver not find an
arena mode doesn't it stick out you
don't sort somehow you know it really
was it wasn't the bus drivers fault you
know we were supposed to have a police
escort and I will say this it is curvy
it is a pass that that you have to take
to get to the underground of the arena
and the bus driver had no he'd never
been there and so we literally we're
going 35 minutes and then the next day
we went to our
it literally took four minutes four
minutes for the hotel to there at least
you found your way as you have
throughout this tournament my last one
for you because this has been such a
conversation coach that the lower seeds
now are are taking this tournament by
storm and and that the the playing field
if you will has been leveled in Cup
major college basketball would you agree
with that and why you know I I think
it's great for the lower suit I think
it's a great for us we felt we had a
good team all year and I know there was
a lot of talk that we might not have
gotten in if we didn't win the Missouri
Valley tournament and I hope this Marcus
conversation because this conferences
like the Missouri Valley our great
conferences top to bottom and it's hard
for us to schedule these huge schedules
because you know to get it the other
side has to agree to us schedule a game
glad it's not us and for us to make some
noise and this thing is great for lower
seeds and I will say that about at this
point if a lower seeds got to this point
you know I know Kansas State tonight
they have found ways to win you know
really good teams I mean Kansas State is
a night they are guarding at an
unbelievable level I mean they're
holding teams do I think 35 percent
and I played it crazy I've watched
Creighton I mean they are as good
offensively and it's watch Kentucky so
you know it's and he wants to you know
Berenbaum Kali you know what what they
did you know in the Virginia game
scoring so they've had a really they're
really good defensively coach really
appreciate the time the whole country is
enjoying watching your team watching the
run and say hi to a sister Jean for us
we please will do rich thanks you bet
absolutely that's Porter Moser head
coach of Loyola basketball here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience